[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de la situación que genera
preocupación entre los expertos de salud
que temen que el bienestar de los
haitianos se está dejando de lado a
medida que se profundizan en la
violencia y la inestabilidad política en
la nación y es que ese país no he
recibido ni una sola dosis de la vacuna
contra kobe y 19 hasta el momento las
autoridades reportan casi 13.000
contagios y poco más de 250 decesos
cifras que serían mucho mayores en una
nación de más de 11 millones de
habitantes para analizar el tema nos
acompaña de gotson pierre él es analista
y periodista desde puerto príncipe-
bienvenido y se prevé que haití recibirá
solamente setecientos cincuenta y seis
mil dosis de la vacuna de astrazéneca a
través del programa kóvacs las dosis
gratuitas debían llegar a más tardar en
mayo pero se prevén retrasos cuál es la
situación real de la pandemia en haití y
para cuándo se esperan las vacunas
hoy hay más o menos 12 mil 840 casos
confirmados 250 250 muertos y 11.000
casos que fueron restablecidos
al inicio de abrir 124 nuevos casos por
el momento no hay otro plazo para llegar
las vacunas después que el gobierno negó
de recibir las dosis de esta técnica ha
prometido por hoy meses y dice que desea
que sea reemplazada por otra vacuna
adaptada el señor viene además de las
vacunas asignadas por kóvacs qué plan
tiene el gobierno para combatir esta
pandemia
digamos que el gobierno no anunció
públicamente un plan siempre hay una
campaña sobre todo mediante los medios
de comunicación masivos para pedir a los
haitianos tomar precauciones
desde que se inició la epidemia podemos
decir que hubo anuncios oficiales y de
dejando saber que hubo un plan para
equipar vivos los hospitales y tener
mejores materiales en los hospitales
pero ahora no se habla de nada listo y
la población toma mucho medicinas
tradicionales y cree que son esas que la
protegen más contra la epidemia mire un
centro de investigación de derechos
humanos es citado en un informe del
departamento de estado de eeuu encontró
que el gobierno haitiano se apropió
indebidamente de más de un millón de
dólares en ayudas destinadas para
enfrentar kobe 19 es la corrupción en
este país un impedimento para llevar a
cabo un plan claro y efectivo contra la
pandemia
ciertamente sabemos que haití tiene que
enfrentar una corrupción muy fuerte y
que es una realidad y que afecta varios
aspectos de la vida del país del
funcionamiento de las administraciones
públicas y privadas hay que recordar que
durante los últimos años más de cuatro
mil millones de dólares de ayuda
definida fueron fueron desviados en
ninguna disposición no fue tomada para
investigar realmente y prever que tal
hecho se renueva y finalmente el otro
problema es que muchos haitianos también
temen ser vacunados a pesar de las
campañas educativas además algunos
funcionarios de salud del país han
expresado su preocupación por la vacuna
de astrazéneca que recientemente ha sido
objeto de escrutinio en europa después
de que un número pequeño de personas
desarrollaran coágulos sanguíneos
inusuales de llegar las vacunas al país
podemos estar frente a un sector
importante de la población que no quiera
ser inoculada
probablemente digamos la gente está
informada de los riesgos con esta vacuna
se alimenta la misión za sobre esto
también no tienen confianza en los
dirigentes políticos que perciben como
personas que no demuestran atención para
su bienestar y que quieren solamente
hacer mucho dinero crean más en sus
medidas creen más en sus medicinas
tradicionales
gotson pierre analista y periodista
desde puerto príncipe de gracias por su
información y a ustedes por estar con
nosotros sigan en france 24
[Música]